foreign
here's a quick example if you invest ten
thousand dollars and you get a ten
percent annual return which by the way
people go what do you get a 10 return if
you look at the S P 500 which
essentially is The Benchmark index for
the stock market it's the top 500
companies uh if you look at that the
average return has been 10 to 12 percent
since its Inception
so this is not an outrageous claim that
you could get a 10 average annual return
not every year some years it may be down
22 percent some years it's up 20 who
knows uh but that ten ten thousand
dollars at a ten percent return and if
you just leave that ten thousand alone
for 40 years here's what happens at year
one you're at ten thousand year ten
you're almost at 26. by year 20 you're
at sixty seven thousand 30 years in
you're at 175 000 and then 40 years in
you're at 452 000 is that not amazing
that's fantastic and remember you only
put in 10.
and so the total growth on that was 442
000 of money that you didn't put in it
was just your interest earning interest
so how does that happen well let's talk
through an example of this and the power
of starting early because a lot of
people they they aren't maybe they're
not there yet Ken either they have debt
they don't have the emergency fund
they're in their 40s or 50s or 60s they
feel like it's too late they feel like
they don't have the knowledge let's take
someone my age George I'm 48. oh boy all
right I wasn't gonna go that old Ken I
was gonna go well the example here you
can see you can change the numbers on
the example but let's say this guy Ben
who starts at 21. right one kid he his
parents went through FPU he did this
stuff and he invests 2 400 bucks a year
you got that just 2400 2400 a year it's
not a lot that's 200 a month yeah and he
stops contributing at age 30. so from 21
to 30 2400 bucks a year the total amount
he contributed was 21 600 bucks now his
buddy Joey a little older he started
investing at age 30 and he invests 2 400
a year as well and he contributes until
he is 67. so instead of nine years he
contributes for 37 years and the total
amount he contributes 88 800.
now in your mind Ken without doing math
you're going well Joey's got to have
more Joey's ahead he invested for a lot
longer period of time you would be
what's known as wrong because at age 67
Ben's investment remember his 21 000 he
put in has grown to 2.1 million dollars
Joey's investment has grown to 1.2
million dollars so that nine-year
difference that nine-year Gap from when
Ben started to when Joey started was a
difference of close to 1 million dollars
is that not wild it's crazy now some
people hear that and they go well wait a
second is it too late for me no because
what about the guy who started at 30.
the best time to plant a tree was 20
years ago the next best time is today
and so regardless of where you're at you
got to start and if you're 50 well still
if you let's say it's 70 years old you
still have 20 years of compound growth
to take advantage of and if you're young
and you follow this plan you go hey what
if I could graduate debt free what if I
could get out of all my debt cut up the
cards have an emergency fund begin
investing 15 within normal income you're
going to be a multi-millionaire if you
just start when you're out of college
and so regardless of your age the key
here is to get started as soon as you
can and the right time to start
investing Ken is once you're out of
Consumer Debt with a fully funded
emergency fund now a lot of people get
mad at us for this because they go oh my
gosh you're going to make me throw away
the company match part of the reason you
don't have the margin to invest 15 is
because you're carrying all this debt
your broke living paycheck to paycheck
and you're trying to get this three
percent match what if for a season you
paused you went down to zero on the
match zero on your investing so that you
had more margins to throw at the debt
now we're added at faster and we're back
to 15 once we come back to investing so
it's a powerful powerful principle to
take advantage of compound interest
compound growth capital appreciation
whatever nerdy word you want to throw on
it and the key is you don't have to be a
genius investor I mean our millionaire
study found that most of them were
mediocre investors that just invested
consistently over a long period of time
in a 401k and a Roth IRA in growth stock
mutual funds and they didn't even pick
the best ones they just went all right
this is not a super volatile investment
it's not a single stock it's not crypto
I'm just going to invest in my
retirement plan and they became
millionaires by doing that and the
average age was 49. so you're right on
track Ken look at that we get started at
49 no they became millionaire average
age for the millionaires in our study of
over 10 000. I see so somewhere younger
some are older gotcha but it just goes
to show you if you just follow a proven
plan you don't have to make a bajillion
dollars to be a doctor or a lawyer you
can build wealth on your terms uh
without having to strike it rich or get
an inheritance or do all these crazy
things